[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
hablamos de lo que ocurre en Irán tras
la muerte de la joven maxa ameniche
quien falleció en un centro de salud
luego de ser detenida por la policía de
la moral por no llevar bien puesto el
velo la indignación entre los jóvenes y
las mujeres desencadenó una serie de
protestas que hasta el momento según las
autoridades dejan un saldo alrededor 40
personas fallecidas 41 personas
fallecidas entre los choques con las
autoridades que reprimen estas
manifestaciones brutalmente mientras que
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos denuncian que son al
menos 70 las personas fallecidas nos
acompaña nuestro estudio Margarita
cadavid internacionalista especialista
en derechos humanos editora de noticias
asociate 3 en El Cairo Egipto experta en
temas de medio oriente y magreb Derechos
Humanos y resolución de conflictos
Margarita Buen día Gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de martes aquí en
directo América que exportar bien o no
un velo y además perdón antes de empezar
a hablar pues qué hace la policía de la
moral en Irán Bueno pues muchas gracias
por la invitación y básicamente desde
1983 se estableció un código muy
estricto de vestimenta para las mujeres
en ese código de vestimenta se habla de
que la mujer tiene que tener cubierto el
cuello y tiene que tener cubierto todo
el pelo no se puede ver absolutamente
nada el pelo lo único que se puede ver
es el rostro las mujeres es un símbolo
que se utilizó digamos y que es parte de
la Revolución islámica porque en 1979 y
a finales de 1978 cuando se hacían las
protestas en contra del chat las mujeres
salían con su luchador El chador es esta
vestimenta negra que usan cubriendo
precisamente el el rostro y el cabello y
es un símbolo era de color negro porque
es el símbolo del martirio de los hijos
del yerno del profeta Entonces cuando se
establece el código de vestimenta
también se estableció desde 1979 justo
después del triunfo de la Revolución una
policía de la moral esa policía de la
moral se encargaba entonces de controlar
que las mujeres usaran la vestimenta
adecuada teniendo en cuenta estos
elementos además cubriendo digamos que
no se vea el cuerpo la figura de la
mujer y durante todos estos años que ya
son 43 años del triunfo de la Revolución
islámica Ese ha sido el código de
vestimenta Y esa ha sido la función de
la policía de la moral con algunos en
algunos años hemos tenido digamos una
relajación Si se quiere nunca se ha
acabado nunca se ha terminado pero
digamos que durante el gobierno de
jatami que era un personaje moderado
estos elementos se habían relajado un
poco y la policía de la moral digamos
que estaba tan pendiente en las calles
de este de esta situación entonces
veíamos que las mujeres empezaban a usar
el velo un poco más atrás y se veía algo
de cabello estamos hablando de
generaciones más jóvenes estas son
generaciones que no vivieron durante la
Revolución islámica que no estuvieron
ahí y que han vivido todo este tiempo
bajo este remix régimen entonces las
protestas por el velo se han vuelto cada
vez más frecuentes en Irán Perdón qué
tanto poder tiene esta policía de la
moral y vamos a retomar el caso de de
esta joven
amenina Quien murió pues obviamente tras
ser detenida por esta policía en un
centro de salud qué tanta
responsabilidad puede tener esta
publicidad teniendo en cuenta que tras
ser liberada fue el centro de salud se
desplomó y pues se murió la policía
recordemos y las autoridades dicen que
ya sufría problemas de salud lo que
desmiente la familia Entonces qué está
pasando ahí y con un régimen tan cerrado
Por así decirlo Cómo saber la verdad
Pues bueno eso es una pregunta digamos
que uno intuye Claro que aquí hubo algo
más no Cuál es la función de la policía
de la moral Pues hay un digamos en el
código penal iraní hay una ley que en
este momento creo que es la 639 si no
estoy mal que esa ley lo que dice es la
las personas que violen el código de
conducta y el código de vestimenta de la
moral pueden tener unos años que van
entre uno y 10 años de cárcel no y
pueden tener también hasta 24 horas de
reclusión Entonces digamos que ella no
era que no estuviera aportando el velo
Ella tenía el velo lo tenía mal puesto
la policía de la moral le llama la
atención como todos sabemos y se la
llevan para un centro digamos que se
supone para reeducación podríamos
llamarlo de esa manera porque ella se
niega a usar el velo Entonces
evidentemente desde el momento en que se
la llevan la responsabilidad de este
individuo la responsabilidad sobre esta
niña es de la policía claro o sea aquí
hay una responsabilidad y el gobierno lo
sabe es decir independientemente de si
van a ir más allá las investigaciones
por lo que tú dices Es un régimen
cerrado Es un régimen que se protege a
sí mismo Es un régimen que está más
abierto a la represión que al cambio y
yo creo que este es un punto de
inflexión porque la gente ya está
exigiendo que haya Y eso es lo diferente
en estas protestas Aquí hay un cambio de
la sociedad iraní pidiendo que estas
cosas estos excesos se detengan porque
lo que hemos visto es un aumento en esos
excesos de la policía de la moral sobre
todo siento yo que con un régimen
ultraconservador la policía de la moral
tiene y se siente más respaldada
entonces creo que eso ha aumentado la
represión en Irán En estos casos
hablemos de eso el presidente
afirmó que él hablaba en su discurso de
Naciones Unidas de respetar a las
mujeres de los derechos humanos de que
las mujeres las mujeres que morían en
occidente pero no voy para adentro no ve
las mujeres que su propio gobierno está
reprimiendo las mujeres que está matando
su propio gobierno también una joven de
20 años que se hizo muy famosa digamos
en la lucha contra esas protestas fue
también fue asesinada durante todas
estas protestas su país encendido un
discurso absolutamente desconectado en
la realidad de su país también el
incidente que tuvo con la periodista
cristiana manpur que no quiso dar la
entrevista porque ella se negó a aportar
este velo entonces podemos ver digamos
políticas más conservadoras de parte de
raisi imposible que que este presidente
Abra los ojos y y pueda decir no sigamos
matando a nuestro propio pueblo Bueno
aquí hay que tener en cuenta dos
elementos que son importantes además de
la corriente que él representa dentro de
Irán que se está corriente
ultraconservadora hay que tener en
cuenta que este líder raíz y que además
de representar esta ideología hay detrás
de todo esto el hecho de que él sería y
es la persona que se proyecta como El
reemplazo de la actual ayatolá que es el
fuckie es decir el que gobierna
realmente el país Entonces en ese orden
de ideas Aquí hay una cosa en juego muy
importante y es el hecho de que raíz si
quiere volver a traer los elementos más
conservadores de la Revolución entonces
hay que tener en cuenta que las mujeres
en Irán tienen derecho a la educación
trabajan digamos que en ese sentido está
mejor que muchos otros países pero el
asunto de el código de vestimenta pasa
más allá de la simple vestimenta porque
como te decía el cuerpo de la mujer y la
vestimenta que se instauró en ese código
es una representación misma de esa
Revolución entonces
qué punto cambiar eso es empezar a
mostrar algo que es mucho más profundo y
son los cambios dentro de la misma
Revolución una Revolución que está
agotada que ya no de no dar respuestas a
las necesidades de la población Entonces
yo creo que aquí verdaderamente tu
pregunta es precisamente lo que está en
juego cuánto tiempo más va a persistir
el régimen en estas políticas con una
sociedad en cambio y una sociedad que ya
evidentemente quiere otra cosa sin duda
Margarita y lamentable también que como
muchas otras sociedades los hombres son
los que deciden sobre el cuerpo de las
mujeres de verdad que como hombre pues
me disculpo con ustedes Muchísimas
gracias Margarita por estar con nosotros
a ustedes Muchas gracias por la
invitación
especialista en derechos humanos
editorial noticias
en el carro Egipto experta en temas de
medio oriente nosotros continuamos esto
es directo